we have a podcast called The Fighter and
kid we are not a couple we are not a
couple nor are we we're so funny
we're going over there can you be mature
about this we're going over we're going
over a moves Jujitsu this is dead
serious so if I get your back it's over
I'm gonna show you the rear naked show
yeah so let's say in some crazy world I
get Brian's back all we're gonna do is
use my chokin here
very quickly how are you gonna get out
of this well you're not I'm not gonna
get out of this but I'm not gonna let
you get to this see it's all about not
letting him get to that stage so he's
got the seat belt on I feel safe here
now I got an issue
these ridiculous huge legs I'm Gonna
Keep rocking here I'm gonna rock here
I'm gonna rock here I'm Gonna Keep
rocking
yeah there it is and there it is Bam
look at this